we pretty much wait waited for him to
punch us
and then i mean
in halftime we came out fighting
and stuff like that but
we can't wait that long we got to be
ready as soon as the freaking kickoffs
start and that's what we got to do we
can't come out flat and then
something to make us mad and now
everybody want to start playing hard to
take a lot
can't wait for somebody to hit us then
start playing hard
kareem hunt who came from a chiefs
organization knows a thing or two about
winning learning that the browns still
have a lot to learn when it comes to
being ready for an inferior opponent
this was the cardinals team that lost
six games in a row and the browns got
caught flat-footed early next thing you
know it's too late for them to do
anything about it and what happened
after the game chris this comes from
michael silver of nfl media
multiple players were yelling toward the
cardinals sideline come get me one of
them was receiver jarvis landry now i
don't know whether this was kind of like
a weird
reference to the otto beckham jr come
get me report from a week or two ago or
whether they would rather play for the
cardinals than the browns but not a good
look
for a browns team that has woefully
underachieved this year yeah i mean it's
not a good look and especially when you
hear the name jarvis landry involved in
the report where you also look and we
know and i saw this happen live where
jarvis landry and freddie kitchens got
into a little bit of an argument on the
sidelines after a series coming off the
field so uh it's not a good look i mean
two things there just to hear that that
hey come get me you know again and is it
two guys i don't know what are they
yelling we're not sure here but just
from what we're you know kind of
inferring it's a little scary especially
with the cardinals who i mean man i mean
it's the cardinals let's let's remember
they're not exactly like a team we're
going oh they're going to be in the
super bowl conversation next year uh and
then you know whenever an owner or a gm
hears we're not ready to play we can't
wait to the second half that just
doesn't sound right and then of course
that's going to get blamed on the head
coach and kareem hunt coming from a guy
like andy reid right where they always
come out hot and ready to punch you in
the mouth he's going like wait what this
is this isn't right so it's not a good
look for the browns right now in freddy
kitchens the more i think about it the
more i am convinced that the sunday
splash report from nfl network about
freddie kitchen's job status which was
so equivocal yeah so ambiguous right i
think kitchens is nervous i think
kitchen sought some sort of an assurance
and that's the most the browns could do
and i think right now you might be right
we we don't have to fast forward very
far yeah we're just 12 days away from it
because you know it no longer happens on
monday it happens on sunday black monday
isn't a thing anymore it's like what
black friday became when all the stores
open on thursday we're going to know
most of the guys who are out on sunday
and i'm not gonna be surprised if
freddie kitchens is one of them chris i
don't think this weekend goes well for
the browns when the ravens come to town
because that's one of the only blemishes
on baltimore's schedule this year and
you know john harbaugh and company are
going to want to make that one right and
that means it's going to go very wrong
for the browns yeah well that's right
and you know again you know
baltimore doesn't want to flirt with
danger here they want to make sure they
got the number one seed locked up and
and and roll into the playoffs and uh so
i'm like hey i think freddy kitchens
will get fired when the season's over
and again i don't you know i don't i
want to say this carefully because i
think freddie kitchens has a chance to
be a good head coach in the future i
just think he was unprepared this time
around he needs to go back be an
offensive coordinator kind of dabble and
get his mind into oh what would i do if
i was a head coach all the things we
talked about that he really didn't get
to prepare himself for uh i think are
really the issues that have
arose as the year has gone on and uh
yeah i think ultimately with that team
and the personalities that maybe a guy
like mike mccarthy is the right type of
guy to get in there in cleveland a guy
that's been there done that can crack
the whip a little bit you know the one
thing you could say about the green bay
packers all the all those years they
were tough they were pretty good in
situational football you know they
always have a plan of attack i didn't
always love their offensive plan of
attack and what they did creativity wise
but you knew they were going to be
prepared and tough and ready to play and
that's what they need a little bit in
cleveland
i think ron rivera is the guy that they
really need to consider i just could see
him getting through to those players he
he kept cam newton
between the buoys
you know because you could tell that cam
newton if
depending upon who the coach is that
could have got that relationship could
have gone haywire and it was never an
issue he always got the most out of cam
newton i think baker mayfield would
benefit from someone like that because
baker mayfield is not currently between
the buoys no and he needs a coach who's
going to keep him in that path and on
that track to being the best quarterback
he can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports